[Music]
if you love Noah Santino as much as we
do you probably jumped for joy when
Sierra Burgess as a loser came out on
Netflix with so much going on in this
movie the fact that his character
doesn't have a last name can easily be
missed watch until the end to find out
how you can contribute to giving him one
first time at the things don't forget to
hit that subscribe button and give this
video a big thumbs up now let's jump
right into this video a little bit about
the movie
Sierra Burgess is a loser is a Netflix
movie that came out on September 7th
2018 this sweet yet controversial movie
may have a different plot than what we
were used to but that's what makes it
comparable to a breath of fresh air
actors Shannon purser and Noah
Centennial combine forces to deliver one
of the best rom-coms of the year that is
unless you've already plagued to all the
boys I've loved before as your favorite
Netflix chick flick up 2018 this movie
is a modern spin on the timeless serrano
de Bergerac story which is a play that
was written by Edmond Rostand in 1897
the screenplay was rewritten by Lindsay
beer who began working on her project in
December of 2016
before long the production got picked up
and began casting at actors it took
about two months for the entire crew to
be found and believe it or not but Noah
Centennial took actor Ben Hardy's spot
for the role of Jamie this makes sense
in yo the last actor to have been casted
into Sierra Burgess is a loser
while Hardy would have been an excellent
choice for Jamie we just can't imagine
anyone claiming this role with the
handsome Noah Centennial rider Lindsey
beer talks sequel Lindsey beer is the
writer and mastermind behind Sierra
Burgess is a loser movie and she's
quickly climbing the ladder to success
this young woman has been working on a
number of screenplays many of which are
still in pre-production the writer
responded in some fan mail and made sure
to answer the questions directed to her
a reoccurring question that beer
addressed was the one asking about
character Jamie's last name before we
spill the beans about why beer didn't
give Jamie a lot
name let's focus on what the writer
confessed to her fans on Twitter bier
stated that she would consider keeping
Jamie a lastname
if Ciara Burgess is a loser was granted
a sequel we know what you're thinking
what a sequel and that's right Netflix
producers and beer have been in contact
about a possible sequel so we're super
excited about that
since this movie has yet to spread its
wings and become a Netflix classic this
decision won't be made anytime soon if
there's one thing that's for sure it's
that you guys will be the first to know
once it gets confirmed Shannon Purser's
first onscreen kiss shannon purser is a
young actress who has been dominating
the scene for a couple of years now she
received her breakout role when she was
cast as barb and stranger things what
are we doing here shortly after she also
received a secondary role on the hit TV
series Riverdale after playing secondary
characters for the beginning of her
acting career her sir was finally given
a new role as the star up Sierra Burgess
is a loser
purser was able to cross some things off
her list her favorite one being
receiving her first onscreen kiss and by
the gorgeous Noah Santini oh no less
despite being terribly nervous about the
whole ordeal cursor says that Centennial
was super sweet about it and we wouldn't
expect anything less from him in order
to make the moment extra-special
directors prevented Santino and purser
from seeing each other until the special
scene arrived synteny Oh being a
sweetheart that he is stated that his
and Purser's kiss was definitely an 11
out of 10
despite being nervous about sharing a
kiss with one of the most charming men
in the biz her sir did what she had to
do and live to enjoy it so if you're
wondering if the kissing scene was
authentic know that it was the real deal
what fans want Jamie's last name to be
it's no secret that actor Noah Santino
has a large following of women
I know while many of them have heart
shapes where their eyes used to be some
of them are even more dedicated than
that so much so that they're super
excited to start fan pages in his honor
one fan who especially loves the actor
wanted to start a Twitter fan account
for Santino's character Jamie however
she couldn't find his last name anywhere
after conducting a thorough research she
realized that Jamie's last name was
nowhere to be found so she did what
anyone else would do she messaged the
movies writer for more information
writer Lindsay beer quickly wrote back
stating that she never gave Jamie a last
name Mike would be open to giving him
one if Netflix granted the production a
sequel beer also stated that she would
be open for recommendations and fans
quickly jumped at the chance for naming
their crush believe it or not but one of
the most popular last name requests as
of yet is Kavinsky the same fan stated
that Peter and James Kavinsky should be
identical cousins which is pretty
hilarious the fan went on to say that
the - all the boys I've loved before and
Ciara Burges is a loser movies should
have a crossover sequel in that Santino
should play the role of Peter and Jamie
Kavinsky while we'd love to see Santino
on the screen again this seems a little
too confusing but then again you never
know what's going to happen how you can
help choose Jamie's last name it's
pretty customary for writers to give
their characters a last name however
some writers decide against this in the
heat of the moment as many people have
realized Jamie from Sierra Burgess as a
loser doesn't have a last name which is
kind of strange if you ask us so why
doesn't he have a last name and what can
we do about it
well it's quite simple writer Lindsay
beer just didn't think that her
character needed one so she decided to
leave it open this can seem pretty silly
especially since neglecting to give your
character a last name is hardly done in
showbiz as a matter of fact the only
character we can think of who doesn't
have a last name is penny from the Big
Bang Theory in order to stop the madness
beer has turned naming Jamie into a fun
game that all her fans can enjoy
basically all you have to do is give
beer a shout-out on Twitter
telling her
which last name you prefer on top of
this you also have to harass Netflix to
grant the movie a sequel sounds simple
enough right
before you go do that to make sure to
tell us which last name you'd give Jamie
in the comments and that's it for our
video thanks for watching and see you
next time
[Music]